la campagne s'accélère pour la
république en marche dans les yvelines
pendant cet entre deux tours de la
présidentielle à louveciennes c'est
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe et le ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics olivier dussopt pts
qui sont venus échanger sur le projet du
président sortant emmanuel macron une
réunion organisée par marie le bec
député des yvelines j'ai souhaité qu'
edouard philippe et olivier dussopt
puissent venir faire une réunion
conjointe parce que finalement c'est à
la fois ce qu'on a voulu incarner le
dépassement du clivage c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a mis en oeuvre
l'essentiel des réformes d'emmanuel
macro et olivier dussopt pts qui a aussi
porté les mesures de soutien aux
entreprises l'occasion de revenir sur de
grands dossiers retraites jeunesse
politique sociale ou encore transition
écologique leur objectif aller chercher
les abstentionnistes et les électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon en troisième place du
classement au premier tour jean luc
mélenchon aujourd'hui ils représentent
près de 20% des voix donc c'est aussi
légitime de se poser la question qu'est
ce qui a séduit cet électorat de jean
luc mélenchon dans la circonscription on
a vu beaucoup de jeunes à aller voter on
sait que c'est un public qui a été
séduit par le discours de jean luc
mélenchon donc force à nous d'aller les
convaincre la carte de france des scores
élevés l'open est la copie conforme de
la carte de france des abstentions donc
plus dur à d'abstention je pense même si
juste super spécialistes puis ira
d'abstention plus le pen fera un soir
est levée pour voir que rien n'est gagné
comme toute élection de toute façon mais
là encore moins que d'habitude les
sondages sont très serrés donc il faut
absolument se mobiliser aux mureaux ce
sont la droite et la gauche qui sont
venus dépasser leurs clivages pour
soutenir emmanuel macron manuel valls
ancien socialiste eric woerth ancien les
républicains ont animé une réunion
publique mardi dernier cette ouverture
qu'on prône c'est la possibilité aussi
de dire aux gens qui ne pensent pas tout
à fait comme nous qui n'ont pas du tout
le même programme que nous mais avec
lequel on peut se retrouver sur certains
points devenu de travailler ensemble pas
de dénaturer ce qu'ils pensent c'est pas
le but mais sur certains points une idée
quand elle est bonne les bonnes d'où
qu'elles viennent ça joue quand il ya
autant de d'abstention autant de
scepticisme de questions qui se posent
ça se joue aussi sur le terrain donc
faut se mobiliser jusqu'à la dernière
minute ça compte encore les tractages le
porte à porte et évidemment les réunions
publiques je soutiens emmanuel macron et
je le dirai ce soir aux mureaux parce
que je pense mais on a besoin d'un
président avec une expérience très forte
même objectif rallier les électeurs dans
un terrain qui n'est pas conquis aux
mureaux emmanuel macron totalise 16 %
contre 60 pour jean luc mélenchon il
faut convaincre les abstentionnistes et
les électeurs de gauche du premier tour
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre choix que de
voter emmanuel macron mais qu'il faut
pas le faire par défaut il faut pas
uniquement le faire contre non il le pen
et les idées d'extrême droite mais il
faut le faire au bout si pour ce présent
la république sans on a bien entendu les
consignes de jean luc mélenchon pas une
voix pour marine le pen on sait certains
de ses électeurs ne vont pas suivre ses
consignes malheureusement je pense qu
emmanuel macron y représente en fait
l'equilibre
l'équilibré entre si vous prenez la
gauche
à l'huile au milieu c'est à dire qu'en
fait d'une manière générale il ya
l'expression courante la voix de la
raison dans la voie de la raison c'est
c'est le milieu forcément sait jamais
des extrêmes des réunions importantes
dans cette dernière ligne droite avant
le second tour